[Music]
foreign
let me show you ready
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Man Battle Network Legacy Collection
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
nice show a developing nation of little
significance tucked away in a remote
corner of Asia the it's rather
fascinating
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
get in there
okay
[Music]
come on
learn that from the best
again
[Music]
six
what's up everyone it's your boy Wheezy
welcome to the street fighter 6 showcase
and how about that new trailer
listen I've been playing Street Fighter
since I was a kid but this new game is
on another level we're talking new ways
to fight crazy new game modes and the
most content we've ever seen in street
fighting so let's get into the game and
get the Showcase started with the latest
from Street Fighter sixes director
takoyuki Nakayama
thanks for tuning in everyone my name is
taka Yuki Nakayama director of Street
Fighter 6.
as you saw in the beginning of our
latest trailer Street Fighter 6 features
significant single player content in the
form of World Tour today I'd like to
tell you more about world tour mode
[Music]
thank you
We Begin the story in Metro City
you'll be able to create an avatar with
a high degree of customization
and assume the role of the protagonist
joining buckler Security Services
training course
[Music]
there you'll meet your coach Luke go
through basic training and set off on
your adventures you're photogenic
gonna help him handle this
[Music]
it's during this basic training course
that you'll meet Bosh your rival and
classmate
and one of the great things about World
Tour is that you'll interact with a slew
of unique characters come on man
so now we're ready to hit the streets
people from various walks of life
inhabit the world of Street Fighter but
they all love a good fight
with a single press of a button you can
seamlessly enter a battle with them
[Applause]
bystanders will also come to see what's
going on
fighter 6 features the tried and true
classic six button control style but
also adds a new four button modern
control style that features three attack
strengths and allows you to perform
special moves with a single button press
okay
you can perform special moves by
pressing a direction and the special
move button
which will let you enjoy the Tactical
side of fighting games
there's also an assist button for
performing combos so use all this as
much as you want
the more you battle the stronger your
avatar becomes
earn experience points through battle to
level up your stats such as Your
vitality
[Music]
some fights have specific objectives
that can be completed to earn more
rewards and items
and add a new wrinkle to combat
you can purchase wearable gear at
clothing shops
[Music]
that gear affects your Avatar's
appearance and their stats and
characteristics as well
the product lineup changes from time to
time so check the stores periodically to
see what's for sale
there's also a variety of eateries to
visit in the game
food purchased from these places can
restore your Vitality give your stats a
temporary boost and mother perks
these items to give yourself a helping
hand during battle
this way
[Music]
here
congrats
from now on you can tell people you're a
student of the great Jamie show
once you knock that back and make it
official anyway
[Music]
just relax it's not booze trust me and
take a swig
it's a family made herbal drink that
really boosts your energy
[Music]
foreign
open up your device to check the various
missions you can take on
this Mission has you going to Metro
City's Chinatown to meet a legendary
fighter becoming the student of a
legendary fighter Grant you access to
their Master action
[Music]
s can be used to destroy wooden boxes
and barrels or leap to far away
platforms you'll have plenty of
opportunities to use Master actions in
different ways but they've all consume
the drive gauge so you'll have to be
careful how often you use them
when traversing the city there are
enemies that will suddenly attack you
that's when you can use the world tour
exclusive move Drive stall to slow the
flow of time
this will slow down the movements of
surrounding enemies and master actions
become more powerful
you can also use this to avoid enemy
attacks or strike first to gain the
advantage when the battle begins
during battle opponents will start to
Glow white this is when you have an
opening to strike during an enemy's
weakest point
Landing a normal attack here will
trigger what we call pressure time and
you'll do more damage than usual however
if you can land a special move it'll
take you one step further you'll put
them into a stun state
this in mind when battling on the
streets
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Lee Fen I'm disappointed in you
when you decide to become a student of a
legendary fighter you can also undertake
special missions
complete those missions to strengthen
the bond between you and the master
you'll open up new stories to learn more
about them
[Music]
you can give the master presents to
strengthen your bond with them and also
see how they react to your gift
[Music]
ing a master's style lets you use their
basic attacks
oh
[Music]
using that style in battle lets you
accumulate experience points which
raises your style level
[Music]
up enough and you can visit your master
to learn new attacks and expand your
move set
[Music]
in addition to experience points you can
also earn skill points through battles
these can be used by opening up your
device and selecting skills
here you can unlock Buffs for your
character that can increase their Punch
or kick strength maximize their vitality
and more the drive stall move we just
touched upon is also unlocked via skill
points
as you can see in world tour mode you
can build a character that's unique to
you by leveling up your style and skills
and customizing your basic and special
attacks
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
your adventure you'll obtain flight
tickets which you can use to travel from
Metro City to other locations via the
world map
[Music]
if you want to learn all of the Styles
and moves you'll have to dedicate some
time to find the legendary Fighters
scattered around the world
[Music]
and you'll find many of your favorite
characters in World Tour
there may be some unexpected appearances
too
[Music]
there's a girl don't you worry my friend
hospitality is our specialty
[Music]
there are characters steeped in mystery
an organization Jim May recognize
all of which come together to immerse
you in the street fighter universe
[Music]
naishal is a large city that serves as
another area to explore in World Tour
complete with its own stores that differ
from the ones you find in Metro City
in contrast to Metro City's Urban
landscape this city has a fairly complex
topography who you'll meet in this new
city will also differ
that's all we have to show you for world
tour mode this time
we hope that you enjoy not only the
battle portion but the story in creating
your own character as well found them
yeah you
look up
[Music]
welcome to the world of street fighter
fighters looking for your next challenge
or just passing through on your journey
either way we're more than happy to have
you
[Applause]
next we'd like to talk about one of the
other main modes in Street Fighter 6 the
battle hub
into the battle Hub players from around
the world can get together and have fun
playing games and doing other activities
access the cabinets on the floor to play
Battle Hub and extreme battle matches
and games at the game center
[Music]
[Applause]
as you saw from the trailer at the
beginning of the show The avatars you
create and train in World Tour can also
Duke It Out
[Music]
Show the World your own personal fighter
in Avatar battles
we also have a new Fighters Club feature
added to Capcom Fighters Network
this will help players get together with
friends or like-minded players
join an already existing club or create
one of your own from scratch
once you've set up the basics of the
club you can also create a customized
emblem
[Music]
not only that but you can design your
very own Club uniforms that all members
can wear
if you have a good idea for a club let
the world know about it
we're looking forward to seeing players
Don their Club colors and enjoy the
battle Hub together
place to be this is your face
eternities signing off
nine eight
seven
six five
four
three
two
I'm still standing
thank you
next up let's talk about some of the
cool stuff we have in fighting ground
in the video you see here we've added a
character damage toddler
during battle Fighters faces bodies and
clothing will get damaged or dirtied up
fight some more some more realistic feel
turned on and off at any time
Rio wins
thank you
additionally sound accessibility options
have been improved for Street Fighter 6.
there are sound effects that will give
you the heads up on the distance between
you and your opponent
the height level of attacks
whether an attack hits is a cross-up or
not
your remaining gauge
we hope that these options will let you
better grasp your situation of your
fight
when you first start the game we've
added a tutorial that explains the
basics of battle and the combat system
in addition to Classic and modern
control types we've added an offline
only control type or an AI assistance
system will perform actions and combos
depending on the distance from an
opponent or the context of the fight
just by pressing an attack button we
call this control type dynamic
and it's recommended for beginner
players for just getting into their
first fighting game
casual matches against friends and
family
or when you're experimenting with a
character for the first time
[Music]
don't expect me to be a pushover
arcade mode is our single player mode
where you'll square off against the
computer
Yoon
yang
been a hot minute since I've seen either
of you but don't worry
I'm doing just fine all on my own
the name's Jamie show
go through each character's story and
you'll unlock a special illustration
after the ending
[Music]
arcade mode also features online
rankings for your score so get out there
and challenge the world
these illustrations can be viewed again
in the gallery try to unlock them all
[Music]
la la
if you're not sure which character is
the right one for you check out the
character guides
which will teach you about each
character's unique traits and how to use
their attacks
each special move comes with a basic
tutorial on how to use them and you can
experiment with them yourself by
pressing the try button
fight
fight just like that perform well and
the characters will shower you with
praises don't forget this moment
[Music]
once you've gotten the basics of a
character down head on over to the combo
trials section
through a basic intermediate and
advanced combos
you can also slow down the game's speed
by 50 to practice your timing
this is a great way for you to expand
your horizons and abilities
player one
are one hole in versus mode you'll find
Team battles
play with or against other players or
the computer in this mode
you can compete in teams single
elimination or double style battles
make sure to turn on your favorite
commentator and get ready for some fun
with your team
dude
[Music]
next up is Extreme battle
this differs from a normal battle
because there are special rules or
gimmicks on the stage for example you
can have a battle where the winner is
the first to knock down their opponent
five times while rampaging goals run
across the stage
or set up a rule where you have to
complete the objectives displayed on
your side of the screen first
a random drones show up and have
different effects when they're destroyed
this will let you have fun with other
players in a party-like setting so give
them a try
extreme battle can be played offline or
in the battle Hub and also in custom
rooms which we'll talk about next
if you want to play with a group of
players online then creating a custom
room is the way to go the four virtual
cabinets in the room can be set to
one-on-one extreme battle or training
mode
custom rooms now allow for up to 16
players at a time we've made great
strides to improve the experience
compared to previous titles
here comes a new Challenger
two time
[Music]
this is a great way for friends to get
together and teach combos
or try out new characters
[Music]
the always popular ranked match lets
players worldwide compete against each
other fight it out with players at your
skill level to earn leading points
[Music]
for Street Fighter 6 in order to burden
the player with less stress than before
we've added a new one-time rank down
protection feature where you won't lose
lead points in certain leads
in addition we have character specific
and random character ranked matches and
ranked match phases which will determine
your rank for a period of time
[Music]
match also returns in Street Fighter 6
where you can play online without any
change to your League points
so what do you think the team working on
Street Fighter 6 has been challenging
themselves to create a game that's going
to become a long-loved street fighter
title that all players can enjoy
it's only a little bit longer but we
can't wait for everyone to enjoy World
Tour fighting ground and battle hub
we hope you look forward to playing
Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
yo that's what I'm talking about those
numos look crazy all right now let's go
to shoe hey Matsumoto Street Fighter 6
is produced
[Music]
everyone I'm Shuhei Matsumoto producer
on Street Fighter 6.
I'd like to walk everyone through what
our plans are for Street Fighter 6 once
the game releases on June 2nd a big part
of Street Fighter's charm is the cast of
characters from around the world that
appear in each game we believe that
Street Fighter is where players can take
control of unique characters with their
own awesome fighting styles for the
players and for us as well the appeal of
the characters themselves is the most
important element of the series with
Street Fighter 6 we're continuing
development to deliver new characters to
you every year today I'd like to
introduce the four Fighters for Year One
top
IC
[Music]
year one will see the introduction of
new characters Rasheed Aki Ed and Akuma
Rasheed joins the fight in summer 2023
Aki in Autumn 2023
Ed in the winter after the new year and
Akuma in Spring 2024
these new year one characters will
appear in World Tour as well
so you can enjoy delving into their lore
in battle Hub we're planning various
events and a store to obtain special
collaboration items
I can't wait to show you what we have
planned for the 2023 season of the
Capcom Pro Tour Street Fighter 6 will be
the main game to commemorate the release
of the new game the Capcom cup 2023
Champion will receive a special one
million dollar Prize Package and the
total prize pool for Capcom Pro Tour
2023 will be over 2 million dollars
both modern and classic control types
will be allowed in the tournament so we
hope you're all excited for a new season
of Capcom Pro Tour Street Fighter 6 is
available for pre-order now
and in addition to the regular version
we're also offering other editions that
include the year one characters and
content
you'll also receive special pre-order
bonuses so please check them out
okay hope you're ready to begin
[Music]
you wanted something more practical
right
on track Academy
in many forms but if you want to start
off in the right footing this city hit
the streets
[Music]
finally we've created a special demo
version of the game so players can enjoy
the first bit of World Tour and some
modes in fighting ground
demo will allow you to create an avatar
that can also be used in the main
version of the game on the same platform
so we hope you put in a lot of time the
Avatar creation feature and have fun
PlayStation 4 and 5 versions of the demo
will be available after this showcase
finishes
hope you enjoy them
we're creating Street Fighter 6 to be
the game that revolutionizes the
fighting game genre
to this end our development team has
taken the lead and challenged themselves
to realize something amazing we're now
at the point where their hard work is
materialized into something we believe
everyone will enjoy and it's coming to
you on June 2nd
that's right you heard it the street
fighter 6 demo is dropping right now
so create your avatar explore world to
emote and stop fighting thanks for
tuning in Street Fighter 6 out June 2nd
maybe you get to throw hands with your
boy Weezy peace
foreign
[Music]
nation of little significance tucked
away in a remote corner of Asia it it's
rather fascinating